all right we begin this hour with a
revealing conversation with comedian
actor and podcaster Mark Maron his
wildly successful podcast WTF is in its
14th year and Marin recently released
his first HBO special called Mark Maron
from Bleak to dark Marin says the best
humor comes from real darkness he spoke
with Anthony Mason about turning his
grief into comedy
you first came here when
I guess it would be 87. Mark Maron
launched his comedy career at the comedy
store in La this is where I worked as
the doorman so here's what here's this
is where I would be come on in party one
come on in just wait here just wait here
were you a tough door man
yeah I thought I was and Mark back here
Fame for the 59 year old comic came late
and not as a comedian but as a podcast
host and more recently as an actor in
series like glow Debbie's the hero and
you're the villain everybody's gonna
hate you even with all the other things
you do yeah you're a stand-up comic at
heart that's all man comedy disarmsings
and it's it protects you there's a
defensiveness involved in it and you
know and I think it helps me survive I
don't want to be negative but
I don't think anything's ever going to
get better ever again
Marin's dark humor is on display in his
new HBO special and don't misunderstand
me I have no hope
um
a recovering addict Now 23 years sober
Marin has never kicked his addiction to
stand up I was terrified all the time I
tell people that for however long it
takes about 80 percent of your energy
goes into pretending you're not afraid
that for me went on for years so how did
you keep going on
because I'm a compulsive weirdo I felt
like I was chosen to do this I don't
I don't know why because there was never
a plan B until he got desperate Plan B
became the podcast he started in 2009
when his comedy career was on the Rocks
because I was looking down the sort of
the tunnel of being a a kind of a
headliner that didn't have a following
and that's a hard life and it's a sad
life this is Mark Maron this is WTF with
me WTF was what he calls a Hail Mary
moment this was the article that sort of
changed my life early on the New York
Times praised the perceptive prickly
host and his ability to coax
surprisingly revealing things from his
guests and then cut to the ark to the
president at my house me and Obama in
2015 the 44th president came to Marin's
garage Studio this is where the you know
the where I talk to the people Marin's
moved since then but his Studio still
not next to his house people who knew
Obama was on they're always like this
were was this where Obama was I'm like
no but it was that chair an unexpected
success the podcast was never meant to
Eclipse his comedy I think these are
most of the notes for the new special
this is like I'm trying to get it down
to an hour and I'm writing it on you
know the ham yard Hotel stationary in
London
it's a nice hotel though I have a hard
time when people my age say aren't you a
little old to still be mad at your
parents
no
no in the HBO special he covers his
troubled relationship with his father my
father's 84 recently diagnosed with
dementia we're all pretty excited
um
I can really bust on my dad to his face
in a very brutal way and he just kills
him who loves it he loves it and look I
know I know it's a terrible disease and
uh
you know and at some point he's he's
he's not going to know who I am anymore
I know that
and I also know
on that day
I will be truly free to what degree is
making comedy out of it therapeutic I
think it's therapeutic but there's also
an edge of Cruelty to it so that's
something you have to accept talking
about the death of his girlfriend the
director Lynn Shelton was more difficult
she did she passed away and it was the
most horrible thing that's ever happened
to me and I'm sure to her
and um
you're talking about grief it's just
something people don't do because it's
frightening and they don't there's a lot
of reasons it's complicated but the day
after Shelton died suddenly of an
undiagnosed blood cancer in May of 2020
Marin shared his grief on his podcast in
the middle of the night I heard her
collapse in the hallway on her way to
the bathroom and I got up and she was on
the floor and she couldn't move I called
the ambulance at around five in the
morning on Friday by
12 45
a.m Saturday she was gone
I thought
it would help people
to go on in that state and it was awful
and I haven't listened to it do you
think it would
ah
it's sad man it was sad you know and
that's the thing it's like you know if I
if I talk about it for a while you know
it it's right there but slowly it began
to work its way into the comedy he was
workshopping in clubs when you were
working through that how did you find
audiences responded to it they were
nervous yeah
yeah because it was not you know I was
not emotionally grounded and they
weren't sure where you were going to go
it wasn't where I was going to go they
weren't sure I was going to keep it
together sometimes he didn't and I would
cry on stage yeah and I didn't know how
to get out of it but because of how I
told you I write yeah I knew eventually
I would have to make it funny because
crying's not that entertaining why was
that relationship so special to you
because you said you never felt anything
like that before the reason was so
powerful is like I was terrified to give
into it why
I don't know it's just like because I'm
emotionally not good not right but to
answer your question you know there's
just nobody really like that person
nobody like Owen Shelton and she
she actually uh you know
you know she just made me uh believe in
myself yeah
that's a big thing
for me it is
how are you now
um I mean I'm okay because I don't
really you know let myself go where I
just went you know 30 seconds ago
I don't mind opening up like totally up
there I more more so than in my life why
is that do you think
because in some ways it's less risky do
you need it probably and I've never been
happier doing it and I don't think I've
ever been better doing it so there's a
part of me that's sort of like you know
I think I'm finally enjoying this thank
you very much
so interesting right you know he met
Lynn Shelton on his podcast in 2015 she
ended up directing him in one of her
films she directed two of his specials
that it all developed from there and he
basically says I wouldn't have a film
career without her wow so a very
important to him obviously you could
tell I really appreciate him opening up
the way that he does on stage and off
stage and I do think that it gives other
people license to say it's okay to be
vulnerable it's very hard to be
vulnerable and put yourself out there
the way that he does vulnerable and
funny and on stage in front of people
yeah use the word I found really
interesting he said he said you know
what I I said how did you develop this
because he said I don't write jokes it's
not what I do I come up with ideas and
then I go on stage and I kind of try to
work them out and he say almost kind of
corner myself that I have to be funny to
get out of this wow and that's what he
does he's so telling and so good I mean
to be called a perceptive prickly host
you don't think is going to be a good
thing but he is he's also in that movie
too Leslie yes exactly he's really good
he's very good he's very good the New
York Times calls him a perceptive
prickly host he calls himself a
compulsive weirdo
I think we all are married good boy
Anthony debate said thank you very much